[Music]
amber heard alleges that a jury in the
very famous trial that she had with
captain jack sparrow
himself the juror was never chosen for
duty
what
did you elaborate what did that mean she
wasn't vetted
[Laughter]
some jack sparrow [ __ ] right here hey
thank you uh so a couple weeks after she
was found liable for defaming johnny
depp right in order to pay the actor
millions of dollars amber heard has
alleged that one of the jurors wouldn't
was not actually the person summoned oh
so you know you get a jury summons yeah
she's saying this cat never got the sum
so that means you could throw the whole
thing
that's what she's trying to do [ __ ]
court games man her legal team says that
the inclusion of the erroneous juror
violated her due process rights and
asked the judge to declare a mistrial
which obviously she wants because she
lost big time yeah she lost the public
in the public eye she lost on the
[ __ ] jury she lost everywhere she's
taking l's everywhere oh dude the l's
are [ __ ] insane in her finances
it's all l's all about we were at a
joshua tree the same time she was going
there to like unwind and [ __ ] and i was
here so hoping that i would see her i
was driving everywhere what were you
gonna do car gold digging horror i was
gonna take a picture with him oh my god
like i was like dude oh my god [ __ ] i
can't believe it's you and then later
i'm like i hate that [ __ ] i hate her i
just like calling women gold digging
horse for no reason at all
with really with really little evidence
he really doesn't he's very sweet no i
actually really like to do it i can
attest hey i just heard that bobby lee
and kalila broke up and guess what i
said immediately what i said that calama
is a gold digging [ __ ] now
i'm you're not the only one there's a
lot of people that think this
so guess what guess why i said it
because she's golden horror because
everyone well because they're broken up
now so that means i have to be against
her right
because that's what usually happens you
have to take a side yeah
and if you take a side it means that the
other side is completely the enemy well
i'm team kalila then dude
so we're beefing so what does that mean
we're beefing so i mean i'm gonna get
out of here so it's bobby what is she
what i think i think bobby's the [ __ ]
gold digging [ __ ] how about that how is
he golden [ __ ] oh dude you didn't make
money off of destiny too
you just sit there and you spend between
the two though i think bobby's more
likely to [ __ ] on the bed that's true
okay yeah you're right that's true which
one's more likely to put a bottle of
alcohol in um pink dick george that's
who that's true that's a [ __ ] fact
well there you have it so yeah collapse
the gold digging [ __ ] what i read
in this article about amber i was
reading about about it on reddit
actually oh our favorite place good
source
i've read it already i was like that's
so interesting that cloud would be such
a gold digging [ __ ] for so many years
because that's what women typically do
yeah they always steal from men bro my
wife made 116 000 and i was like
that's mine she's a gold digging horse
somehow
i'll find a way she'll find a way to
take it from you yeah
she find a way to take her money from
you yeah that's rightfully yours dude i
was like i don't know how she's called
ignore but she's probably one you'll
figure it out cause you want your
counter money just watch out man uh so
yeah as you can tell there's not much to
this story other than that
um there's a new document filed by uh
amber heard's legal team they they
offered new details saying that a 77
year old was randomly selected for jury
duty but instead a 52 year old with the
same last name
who apparently lives at the same address
came to the court served as a juror
throughout the trial their names were
both redacted the documents so can we
sounds like a clerical he busted a mulan
that's what happened
my father is too old i will go in his
place
the junior took over
so uh i was asked for some serious
advice right this guy was like dude joe
man i'm going through these problems
like i just don't know how to handle
this it just keeps happening to me i'm
like what's going on and he's like
man how do you prevent
all these gold digger hoes taking your
money i know dude
such a good question it was a serious
question would you tell him
he's like dude you're plowing so many
fans how do you keep them from being
gold digging away and you keep them from
being so discreet it's like if you have
no money to give them because it's all
on luna then oh that's really good
that's the ultimate hack because then
these gold digging horns are like wait a
minute i thought this was a million
dollars how come it's it's 25 cents
on an update on you
jeez
joke's on you yeah and that's exactly
what happened is like he was just like
yo man how you know how do you keep them
away but still like have a good
relationship you know and i was like so
how many have have they taken from you
and you goes oh you know i just asked
these girls out on date and i paid [ __ ]
and like it ends at that and i'm like
damn dude you got taken advantage of man
you took them out on a date they didn't
even do anything cause yeah i was like
damn that sucks dude dude when that
happens though
what actually helps if you actually are
in this situation if you just yell at
the chick like i don't even get a
[ __ ] or anything like [ __ ] you you
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you you just gotta be like yo what
what am i paying this [ __ ] for my dick's
not gonna suck itself
and then you go and get a prostitute no
no no no then the chick comes to her
sense snaps him yes snaps him back into
reality
oh [ __ ] whoa we're overstepping my bad
hang on i wasn't in actual like reality
and that's called setting a boundary
yeah because you got to put your foot
down yeah put your foot down you can't
let these hoes take your money it's
taking your money
if you spend three things at dinner and
they're not gonna blow you if you just
start yelling at them in the parking lot
they're going to blow you up
even two figs
i was like two figs high to fix high
it's a high toothpick above 50 above 50
yeah
crazy dollars i was like dude i'm taking
you to a fine establishment i [ __ ]
got you at ihop oh yeah
like dude this is the breakfast of
international 60 bucks especially now oh
[ __ ] it's expensive what the [ __ ] and
you got two ojs you know those were five
bucks a pop two legends no bj's no dude
since i'm saying no but legit though
like like kind of breaking character for
a minute i really had that question no
me too
breaking character yeah i won't even
drive you home if you're not gonna blow
me no
breaking character i i i literally had a
fan asking me
how do you keep these girls from not
taking money from
don't give them money exactly it's it's
literally that simple right just don't
[ __ ] give girls money he's probably
used to buying affection he exactly
right so so he's putting himself in this
[ __ ] trap right and he's giving all
these [ __ ] gifts because i i was so
curious i was like i can't believe these
dudes exist yeah this is a there's a
whole website dedicated to this it's
called reddit
yeah ready read it no that's the only
fans like the old boys are on reddit we
know that no and then i was i felt
genuinely sorry for the dude because i
was like wait so i was just like so
[ __ ] confused and i'm like so
you okay so so so in these situations
you take them out shopping they didn't
even [ __ ] ask for it he goes well we
have to do something they actually tell
you no please don't take me i don't like
it so they take them to the mall or
whatever right and then they're like oh
i like that shirt it's like whatever i'm
like
you're just volunteering to spend money
and you're blaming them
because looking around for being a gold
digger because you're giving them mad
gifts and i'm like what the [ __ ] and in
his mind he's like these hoes keep
taking my money
well here's here's what you gotta do you
gotta state your intentions right so
your your urban outfitters with this
chicken she's like looking at some
blouse
and she's like oh i kind of like this
you're like yeah but i bet you're not
gonna stop my dick when i buy it for you
yeah and then you you seated it now
she's like thinking about that because
well maybe i will win every time
stupid you gotta plant the scene yeah
you're setting the deck yeah yeah of
course yeah you gotta set the table and
that's what i learned from that book the
pickup artist
me too
then
is when she goes hey i'm going to try
this on the dressing room when she goes
into the dressing room i'm already there
with my pants down
really good by the way it's very
thoughtful it's really good it's just
hanging right there she knows what to do
and the best thing is you tell the
person who's collecting on the clothes
you're like
hey i'm just going to go yeah try some
of this [ __ ] on and then you sneak into
the one that your chick's going into oh
and then you share it
but she doesn't know that
she screams at you you get arrested and
she's she screams boundaries and you're
like
yeah i set those earlier
[Laughter]
yeah i know yeah i literally did that i
did that
do you want the blouse or not yeah you
[ __ ] gold digger gold digging horrors
man you guys are too [ __ ] in your
face you got to be more subtle like you
gotta be like do you like this shirt or
whatever on me and then she's like yeah
well hold on you go into the dressing
room you put on the shirt you take off
your pants completely that's so hard as
rocks and then you open the [ __ ] door
and you go like this shirt and it's a
it's a clothes collecting lady
[ __ ] sorry i thought you were somebody
else sorry but you're a gold digging
horde too i know it you're just not the
right one yeah just want to set some
boundaries with you too you know you're
like wow like 25 minutes to fluff this
penis
it certainly isn't going to take care of
itself
and you're like sorry i was just
pitching sorry i was like yeah you know
i'm realizing as everyone's sharing a
little bit of like how they would handle
the situation don't say everyone i'm
realizing that we're all pretty [ __ ]
alpha dude oh
super alpha are you serious yeah yeah i
mean some people are threatened by that
dude we're [ __ ] out that's why we
hang out on reddit because we're alpha
male 1
is that the new song sigma
no we're alpha male 1 we're alpha dude
we're literally alpha males too so alpha
i'm like well the sigma male is the lone
wolf right it's like
i am i'm not a part of anything because
i ride alone i'm the wolverine let me
tell you how alpha i am
tell us me and my wife are going through
in vitro fertilization
[Music]
[Laughter]
streaming
you